[Applause]
it's being put in a ass
Hey find out what happens when people
start being all polite and start being
real mad real when I first entered the
house needless to say I was a little
surprised to meet the other roommates
hey what's going on
my name is Chad I don't really hang out
with too many black people
[Music]
my name is Terry and yeah I went to
prison
Wilke hitch and we entire period um I
mean that I better not catch you're
standing up pee you sit down when you
pee one Stan now get your fat ass on
that either
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he didn't know what he's getting himself
into you know they gave us a job running
the juice bar all right enjoy it's like
I wasn't really crazy about the way some
of the other roommates acted in the
juice
[Music]
[Applause]
fine fine make your juice I don't know
they didn't have much respect for the
job all right guys you know you we're
here to work not play you know we can't
have this conversation every day what is
your problem then why you want to work
so hard huh yeah man America want to see
us live now work
look at me America families and Jews
bitch I'm thirsty
and a banana cognac yecch
pony ponies
[Applause]